[Music]
now I'm gonna we're gonna have a talk
from Laura welter she's a PhD linguist
who came to us originally with the
Rosetta project and Jim O'Neill pointed
out at lunch that really language in and
of itself is kind of a long-term
institution and it is one of the things
that allows culture to persist even
across in some cases genocides and Wars
and huge transitions and Laura not only
has worked in dying languages but also
has been working with us as the head of
our library projects and how to make
language and meaning persist over
thousands of years
so dr. Laura Walter so I'm keenly aware
that I'm occupying the the nap slots and
I decided not to do slides and instead
to do kind of an old-school
show-and-tell
which I think is an appropriate way to
present something about language I'm
gonna use just language to communicate
something to you and if I were really
hardcore about it I wouldn't even have
notes but some of my thinking around the
things that I'm going to talk about is
is really very new and so there's a
chance that I could forget everything I
wanted to say and what I want to say is
is related to a white paper that I'm
working on for an edited volume about
the future of linguistic data especially
archive linguistic data kind of drawing
from my experience with with working on
the documentation of human languages and
language archives but I'm talking to an
academic crowd and I'm the one who can
actually talk about I have permission
because I work for the long now
foundation to talk about the very long
view so am i thinking about that is the
is coming from the perspective of sort
of language archives around the world
that are helping to support the work of
linguists who are doing language
documentation in the communities that
are relying on them to try to bring
their their languages back so it's all
pretty new but to give you some context
I worked at the long now foundation here
for about 15 years now and I came here
originally as an academic linguist to
work on the Rosetta project and I've
since kind of expanded to work on other
language projects we here have here at
Long now on our library projects more
broadly so I think of a lot of the work
that we do here outside of the clock as
having to do with a long now library and
this is like one instantiation of the
library that you see up here we call
this the manual for civilization it's
currently in in development so it's a
it's a physical book collection but the
idea is you know whatever information
might be useful to help support and
sustain civilization over the very long
term I helped develop in both content
and inform the original rosetta disk and
you can see the first one that we
created there in the the curio cabinet
behind you it's in a sphere I thought it
would pass one around this version is
the version that's in the in the
Smithsonian I'll pass it around with you
actually need a microscope to read it so
you won't be able be able to read it
with this magnifying glass but you can
you can get a bit of a closer look at it
you know the the project if you haven't
heard about it before is is both a
project in collecting information on
human languages and language
documentation as well as an experiment
in very long-term archiving on the scale
of thousands of years and Xander if I
could start you off kind of passing that
around with the microscope there's also
a wearable version by the way if you
want to take a closer look I have one
with me so the the Rosetta project and
the disk was originally inspired by this
rosetta stone artifact this isn't the
actual artifact the actual artifact is a
the British Museum this is the portable
version I called this the eye stone it's
in the British Museum
yeah and it's it's it's about this tall
and it's got incredibly it almost has
microscopic writing on it in fact and so
this this artifact which was discovered
in Egypt by Notah Napoleon's soldiers
and eventually made its way into the
hands of somebody shampo Leone who was
able to actually decipher it was key to
deciphering the the ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphic script and the way that
worked is there's this is the same text
a decree written three different times
and on the bottom here you have ancient
Greek in the middle here you have kind
of a script a later script form of
Egyptian called demonic and then at the
top you have the Egyptian hieroglyphs
and at the time people thought it it
probably represented human language but
they had no no key for it and it was the
rosetta stone because of its parallel
structure that enabled people to kind of
work their way back and figure out that
that this was actually representing a
spoken language and it turns out that
there were lots and lots of other texts
that were then able to be transcribed
and translated once you have this kind
of this kind of key it's not pass that
around as well sure my stone with you so
so using that as our model we also
collected parallel information that is
the same information for as many
languages of the world as we could now
there are about 7,000 languages spoken
in the world today and those have many
dialects within them so there's a lot of
linguistic diversities not of course as
broader as deep as the world's
biological diversity but it's still
considerable we got documentation for as
many languages as we could but not all
of the languages of the world are very
well described so a lot of languages
don't have any documentation and and we
needed to try to collect some and that's
part of the work of what our panel X
project is doing in vocabulary but
there's over a thousand languages
represented on the disk in some form or
another and the one that I'm that's
being
around there's about 13,000 microscopic
pages of documentation that you can read
at optical magnification this with a
microscope at about a thousand times
power so it's intended to be the it's
like an intentional Rosetta start read
as rosetta stone artifact for the future
and we think about it kind of like a
secret decoder ring to whatever
information we lay may leave to the
future in the form of our human
languages and as far as the content on
it goes the is great content to
represent humanity because it's a
picture of our linguistic and cultural
diversity at the beginning of the 21st
century and this picture is going to
change pretty drastically probably over
the next few hundred years because we're
projecting that we're probably going to
lose maybe as much as thirty five to
forty percent of the world's linguistic
diversity over the next few centuries
the current rate is about six languages
per year so the question is whether or
not that's going to speed up or slow
down but this is what we're we're seeing
and so you can kind of see what the
writing on the wall is in most of
languages of the world of course don't
have you know a billion speakers or
millions of speakers they have more like
ten thousand speakers and for most of
human history that was just a normal
sized human language it could be very
viable even smaller languages like the
ones that I've worked on could be very
viable but in sort of the modern era
where we're very globally connected
there are languages with great global
economic power it's really hard for
these smaller languages to make a go of
it and so what we're seeing is that
people are shifting away from these
languages to more dominant ones and
they're leaving their heritage languages
behind there's various reasons for doing
this throughout history some of the
things that we've seen here in the
United States have been outright
oppression forced assimilation boarding
schools relocations you know even
genocide so this has happened in places
around the world it's happening today so
to step outside of lum now and
project you know I started out my work
as an academic linguist and had been
working as a graduate student researcher
to document and describe some of the
most critically endangered languages in
native North America particularly around
the Midwest where I grew up and they
have very few speakers and most of them
are elderly and when I started my work
on a particular language there was there
were 50 speakers left and I worked with
many people who are little no longer
here and I fully expected when I was
doing this documentation work that the
language was going to go extinct in my
lifetime and we're now to the point you
know I've kept one foot in this work and
went out to the point that there's about
five speakers of this language left
maybe maybe that but the work that we
have done on language documentation with
the last speakers including creating
dictionaries there's a dissertation
that's been written that's a grammar
we've done NSF funded projects to
document stories and record those on
video and transcribe them this is the
work that is going to be very helpful to
the next generation I've also worked
with the next generation on trying to
bring this language back into modern and
and vital use again and teaching the
language to an even younger generation
of children so that's the first thing
that happens when languages become
endangered and threatened you see that
the children are no longer speaking it
and of course as that generation ages
that's when the language is going to to
go extinct so every language is just
kind of one generation away from
extinction actually it's about a process
of perpetuating it across generations
that keeps these this alive so this is
happening really all over the world
today
you know half of the languages of the
world are endangered in some form or
another and out long now we talk about
the possibility of future
societal collapse or civilizational
collapse and we look to examples in the
past Jared diamonds examples of
civilizational collapse and it's also of
course one of the purposes of the manual
for civilization when the when this
project is fully realized but the way I
look at it each endangered language is a
case study in civilizational collapse
you know we ask ourselves could it
happen but it's actually happening all
around us it's happening right now
as these languages and cultures the
languages and the cultures they helped
build disappear in many language
communities around the world are going
back to archived language data is that
these are called sometimes language
reclamation projects or revitalization
projects to try to bring their languages
back into modern use again and that's
that's a tough thing to do it's a tough
thing to do and there's a lot of
questions around you know when you bring
a language back from the brink is it
still like the same language you know
all languages change over time languages
that come back from the brink like that
probably even more they may go through a
process of creolization we don't know
but there's still I I recently had a
really interesting take on this from a
man who's meeow meeow
and he worked with his family to bring
his language back into into use in his
community and into use and his family
and his reasons for doing it I think are
really interesting is because he wanted
to reconnect with his it wasn't because
he wanted to bring the language back for
the languages sake he wanted to bring it
back so that the knowledge that his
ancestors had could live again he felt
like there was a very important need for
that knowledge to exist in the modern
world and he wanted to to make that
happen through his language and so the
people who are working on these
revitalization projects around the world
some of which I'm involved with
somewhere which are happening even here
in the Bay Area these
our efforts at civilizational
maintenance they are critically
dependent on archived materials of the
kind of documentation that I worked on I
thought I'd pass around this example of
language documentation this is a an old
publication of is called Jana texts this
is a work that was compiled by the
linguist Edward Sapir and example of one
kind of language documentation it's a
collection of texts that are translated
and annotated and and analyzed and you
could do a lot with a book like this and
when edward sapir met Ishi i don't know
how many of you know this story of Ishi
but you know the last speaker of the
Yaqui language the reason he could
communicate with him at all is because
he knew jana he knew some jana and jana
is an extinct language today but the
only reason we have you know ishii we
have a few recordings of stories he told
and I worked on some of these as a
graduate student and the only way that
we have any understanding of what he's
saying is because of the the archive
documentation work on Jana so this is
one example of that pass it around so
back to the Rosetta project so I want to
tie these ideas together about about
endangered languages language
maintenance the relationship of those
communities to archival records because
in the Rosetta project the other side of
course is that we're trying to do this
very long-term archiving and but when I
came to the Rosetta project I thought
that my role was going to be I was going
to help save these languages I was going
to help bring them back and the you know
the Rosetta project was going to be the
thing that was going to do that but the
Rosetta disk and the Rosetta project is
not going to save any language there's
certainly there's not enough information
on any language on the Rosetta disk to
save it and if you really wanted to
document a language I mean you look at
all of the information we have on the
English language that's probably one of
the better documented languages we have
and most the languages of the world
happened
thing like that so you could have some
basic elements of documentation like a
set of texts a dictionary and a grammar
that would be very valuable things to
have but none of these is going to
actually save a language because the
language needs to be lived not archived
what the result and the result is can do
is we can help create a better
environment that sees language diversity
as a benefit to humanity rather than as
a threat which is the way most people
see languages and one of the pressures
that work against their maintenance over
time so the Rosetta project I decided
the Rosetta just isn't about saving
languages but it is about creating a
better context and environment for them
so I wizened up and then I realized that
the big problem that the Rosetta project
was trying to solve is actually one of
methods and materials for long-term
archiving so we just need to figure out
the right way to store information so
that we can last it the information can
last a long time
so you know we're going to write all
this information we're going to put it
on it to a nickel disk and we can read
it with a microscope so even if though
we don't have a very broad and deep
information on any language it's going
to be the kind of information that's
going to last a thousand years from now
we've got everybody beat in this
department so it turns out that you can
actually scratch the disk and obliterate
hundreds of languages probably with just
running your your your nail over it and
I'm I'm working on that problem but but
maybe it's better to store information
in some kind of forever harddrive right
or maybe by nano manipulating court
structures like there's a researcher by
the name of Peter kazansky that's
looking at that as a new way of storing
information or maybe we should store
data in DNA I mean that's got you know
incredible capacity so there's there's
projects that are emerging all the time
to try to explore new store everything
forever technologies but then I realize
all of these all of these other efforts
have a problem
so I wizened up and I realized it
actually in a code we have an encoding
problem so all of these projects that
are working on very long-term archiving
are now coming to long now and asking
for our curated language data to put in
their store everything for every media
whether its DNA or whether it's in this
quartz structure what-have-you and it's
gonna be buried or it's gonna be stored
in a salt mine or maybe it's gonna be
blasted into space or what-have-you and
I don't mean to make light of these
projects where I actually think these
projects are really cool and important
and we're partnering with a lot of them
but I realized that all of these efforts
including the Rosetta project has a
pretty serious encoding problem so I'll
use an example of DNA so let's say you
wanted to encode a human story like
let's say Jack and the Beanstalk we want
to tell a story in English of Jack and
the Beanstalk and we want to encode it
in DNA you know one way you could do
that is you could just take the waveform
and transfer transform that into ones
and zeroes and put that onto the disk we
did work to get some data data in DNA in
the way it was done is that the the
spoken language the words were turned
into writing so the first layer of
encoding there though is language and
people forget that human language is an
encoding of human experience in a
particular environment on planet earth
right so language is the first encoding
if you write language if you create a
writing system for it then that's
another layer of encoding you've now
encoded spoken language so there's two
layers in if you take the writing and
then turn that into binary ones and
zeros that's a third layer and that I
want to say is not a simple thing to do
so I don't know how many of you have
heard of the Unicode standard but the
Unicode standard is a way to uniquely
represent any character in any language
on earth with a unique encoding in a
digital form this is the fifth edition
there now unlike the 11th edition and
it's even thicker than this right so
that's not a simple encoding so okay so
now we're in digital you want to go from
digital to DNA right so you're going to
have to translate your ones and
Zero's into the nucleotides of DNA so
now we're into what three four layers of
encoding and you want your DNA to be
this long-term forever
archive so first of all somebody's gonna
have you know thousand years from now or
more somebody's gonna have to discover
this they're gonna have to know that
there's actually information there so
they're gonna and then they're gonna
have to figure out how they're gonna how
they're gonna get out that data and once
they do they have to read it they have
to know to convert it back into ones and
zeros and from the ones and zeros back
to a writing system and then go from the
writing back to the spoken language and
when they get there then they have some
kind of spoken texts or some some bit of
language right what the heck does it
mean right how do they know a thousand
years in the future 2,000 years what
what was what was actually said and
meant by Jack in the Beanstalk so the
real problem the real problem I think
that is at the base of all of these
questions is how do we preserve meaning
so to go back to our example of the the
rosetta stone if we had an intentional
message left to us by some ancient
Egyptian that we need its decode how
could we really understand what that
meant you know we have the rosetta stone
we have lots of texts of ancient
Egyptian so we have a big corpus to use
we understand the grammatical structure
we could probably come up with something
that's a reasonable approximation but
could we be really sure I think without
a native speaker you really can't you
would just there would be some
probability there but it's not a sure
thing so meaning is actually created by
all of the connections between things
that humans make and encode in their
languages and their in their cultures
and it's highly complex and for a
language to have meaning i postulate
that it must be lived but as we've seen
language is precarious lived language is
precarious the knowledge that we pass on
from generation to generation through
them is ephemeral and it's easily lost
so we should make an archival backup
right and there's lots of challenges
that who was shown with this as well
right
the Rosetta project is helping figure
out how to do this and we're getting
better at it but it's still a bit of a
challenge so the best answer I have for
this problem I think so far the problem
of how we preserve meaning is that we
need both we need to write things down
and we need to put them in our archives
but over time like those texts of Jana
they become discontinuous from any lived
event and left alone they become
disembodied and over long periods of
time they become dissing cultured they
lose meaning lived lived experience is
what provides the meaning archives store
information lived experience stores
knowledge both are precarious but in a
healthy society they should be in
continual dialogue with each other and
each providing critical support for the
other thank you
[Applause]
[Music]